well this is a time when many
conservatives are licking their wounds
sulking whining even worse they're
sniping at each other and this is all of
course a massive mistake now you know I
may not be the greatest Bastion of
optimism and positivity in the world I
realize that I'm not the guy you turn to
for pep talk usually but
I also am not one for pouting and it's
Unbecoming of a grown man to pout or
sulk and besides I prefer to stay on
offense even after a loss in fact
especially after a loss and that's why
we're still playing offense here in
Tennessee I've already told you about
the bill filed this week the very first
piece of legislation in the session Bill
one which will ban so-called gender
affirmation quote unquote procedures on
minors
and the media has lamented that our bill
is among the strictest in the nation and
I will proudly admit that we are guilty
as charged as far as that goes our
legislation not only bans the medical
abuse of gender confused minors but it
also empowers the victims to sue those
who are responsible for it and and what
I believe I believe this is an
unprecedented step the victims of this
Butchery will even be given the right to
sue their parents after all parents who
bring their children to doctors to be
sterilized and castrated and butchered
are the primary villains here even more
than the doctors I would say
I mean the doctor is a mercenary fraud
hurting children for profit betraying
his oath to do no harm it's hard to get
lower than that but the parents somehow
succeed as they have are they are bound
by an oath before God to love and
protect their children whether they have
said such an oath out loud or not they
are bound by it from the moment that
their children are conceived
and those parents who fail to live up to
it
will pay the price as as well they
should
but child abuse comes in many and
diverse and deranged forms uh these days
and our goal must be to root it out
expose it punish it in every form that
brings us to Bill three of the
legislative session just filed by
Tennessee Senate Majority Leader Jack
Johnson also one of the principal
architects of uh our anti-mutilation
bill
Bill 3 will ban and criminalize any drag
performance involving children the hill
reports quote Tennessee Senate Majority
Leader Jack Johnson a republican has
introduced legislation to prohibit drag
entertainers from performing on public
property or at private functions where
their performance may be viewed by a
minor Johnson's bill would amend a state
law preventing adult-oriented businesses
like strip clubs from operating within a
thousand feet of schools public public
parks or places of worship to include
adult Cabaret performances including
those of exotic dancers and male or
female impersonators Johnson told WKRN
TV in Nashville this week that the bill
is designed to prevent drag shows that
are sexual in nature from being
performed in places where children may
be present should the bill Advance
through Tennessee's
republican-controlled legislature and
receive the approval of Governor Bill
Lee boasted with both of which things I
think certainly will happen first time
offenders would be guilty of a Class A
misdemeanor punishable by jail time of
up to a year and a fine of 2500 repeat
offenders would be charged with a Class
E felony which carries a prison sentence
of up to six years and fines totaling up
to three thousand dollars
so we have the anti-mutilation bill
this now is the anti-groomer bill
and predictably the groomers are not
happy about it our local news channel 5
interviewed uh some some in the latter
group the groomers who are upset to get
their reaction and uh let's see some of
that
this bill would also ban drag shows
where children may be present it's
extremely uh hurtful Mac puts on
pageants for male impersonators and
Divas
and she's the Nashville Pride president
it would devastate our pride parade our
pride festivals according to state
senator Jack Johnson they were
inappropriate performances in public
which sparked the bill it is illegal to
take your child to a strip club and yet
we're going to allow a drag show that
has blatantly explicit sexual activity
taking place in a public park where kids
are present no we're going to stop that
we also talked to Chris Sanders at the
Tennessee equality project he says it's
frustrating that the first two bills
introduced for this legislative season
Target them merely dressing in the
clothing of a different gender
is not something that should be
regulated ever
not in our American tradition not
according to our constitution in the
Bill of Rights and not according to
common sense if dry kings and queens
perform in public they could be charged
with a misdemeanor and the second
offense is a felony it's just not right
it's not our American tradition the
stifle expression Rebecca Phil's freedom
of speech and expression should be
protected the wording is very violent to
trans people and it's dangerous and it's
homophobic and I think that there's a
very slippery slope
a slippery slope yes watch out for that
slippery slope folks first you tell
adults they can't perform in Burlesque
for children and the next thing you know
uh
chaos has ensued and by chaos we mean
that children are given the basic
protections they need and deserve this
is what counts as chaos in the minds of
the groomers
indeed it is homophobic she says because
apparently in her mind sexual
performances for children are a
fundamental and inextricable part of Gay
Culture that is her claim evidently
that's what she is saying
there's a reason why these people panic
over the possibility that they may not
be able to sexualize Children anymore
for one thing they get a thrill out of
doing so they derive sick satisfaction
from it and they're upset that they're
uh that this favorite pastime of theirs
will now be taken away but they also
realize that their ideological project
their cultural agenda depends on
destroying childhood innocence as
quickly and efficiently as possible
and they're going to find it more
difficult to recruit children into their
cult if they can't first corrupt them
and that's why they're upset
so I make that's why this law is
necessary and similar laws should be
adopted in every red state in the
country if you live in Red State it
doesn't have a law like this uh you need
to be reaching out to your local
legislators and ask them why you don't
but there are you know other other you
know basically this all boils down to
the benefits of a law like this first
the most obvious benefit is again it
protects kids you know in this country
there are special laws and policies put
in place to protect all kinds of
different special groups and victim
classes and usually the laws are
unnecessary and the special group
neither needs nor deserves nor has any
legal right to the extra protections
that they're being given
but children are in fact a special group
and they are in fact morally and legally
entitled to extra protections
the law is meant to treat them
differently
with special care and concern for their
well-being
largely because we recognize that they
can't fully watch out for and care for
themselves
and so and so then they functional and
decent Society recognizes that
and offers them extra protections
you could tell everything you need to
know about a society based on how it
treats its children and based on what it
law what its laws say about children
and that's how you know that we are a
depraved and dying Society because
children are not only deprived of
special protections even as special
protections are awarded to groups of
infantilized adults but worse the law
often specifically denies children even
the most basic and fundamental rights
and protections that everybody else has
such as the right to life
this is all backwards
and we're going to set it right
second politically this is a winner
because not only do decent Americans
want kids to be protected but also puts
the other side of the position uh that
you you heard in that news clip of
having to explicitly defend and
affirmatively argue for the sexual
exploitation of children
we already know that they're in favor of
such things but if you don't wage a
legal assault on it they'll never have
to openly own this horrific position
it's good for the public to hear
when they they make the case it's good
for the public to hear them make the
case
so the public can see
who they are
third finally
you know politics may be Downstream from
culture
but also sometimes culture is Downstream
from politics it's not quite as simple
as we sometimes make it out to be and
what I mean is that when the law is
permissive of something
the public is more likely to see that
thing as morally acceptable
when the law forbids something
the public is more likely to see it as
morally unacceptable
this is just a fact
um the the the law is not simply a
reflection of public opinion
sometimes it doesn't reflect public
opinion at all
but at other times it also shapes public
opinion
this is why the left fight so hard to
change the law to accommodate and affirm
their wickedness and their various
perversions
they do it not just so that they have
permission to act as they want
but also so that the public will see
their actions as acceptable even
admirable
this is why we have to fight
in the culture
but also in the State House
and that's what we're trying to do here
we aren't dissuaded I'm certainly not
in fact I never felt more motivated
and I'll do it for this portion of the
show is move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
on Monday Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]